bring you more now on that plane crash
in Kazakhstan with reports of a hundred
people on board
Alexandra godfrid joins me now on the
phone from Moscow Alexandra at this
stage I know it's happened very recently
what do we know at this stage according
to the press service of the airport
Felicia took off which is a lot I in
Kazakhstan very soon after taking off
the plane disappeared from the Raiders
and what they're saying is that it
crashed during the takeoff so it is at
this point not clear whether it's
questions were building and that that's
why it happened or as a result of
something happening in reality it's
described what they're saying is that
they're confirming seven people died in
this accident they're saying that there
is education going on at this moment
this was a domestic flight going from
the Kazakhstan town of Armitage to a
capital of Kazakhstan Nursultan
physically but we remained that was Anna
previously there was 95 people on board
according to some reports there was
hundred because like five people were
members of the killing shafts piratin
and research that is what we know at
this point Alexandra I believe it was a
BEC air jet what do we know about their
safety record is there a concern about
about air safety in Kazakhstan we didn't
hear anything about plane crashes in
Kazakhstan in recent recent years and
there is regular flights it's a big
country they have regular flights also
with Russia for instance but there was
no reports of any incidents with the
place in Kazakhstan or with this company
that I know of that's Alexandra God
Freud speaking to us on the phone there
from Moscow will be bringing you much
more on that as we get it Thank You
Alexandra